prendre une série au long cours comme
thorgal un hyper sa femme il part à sa
recherche il a retrouvé son fils qui
disparaît entre bédéphiles on parle bien
sûr de bd au 25 ans didier de bernardi
n'a raté qu'un seul festival de buts
cette année encore il fait partie des
premiers de la file aujourd'hui c'est
qu'un certain dit fichier des auteurs
qui sont difficiles à avoir qui sont
rares et donc bah il faut être dans les
premiers sinon après on passe la journée
pour un seul auteur didier espère
compléter sa collection il possède plus
de 5000 ouvrages
une passion qu'il partage avec des
auteurs devenus pour certains des amis
un regard amusé et attendri aussi parce
que c'est c'est le phénomène des des
gens qui sont vraiment passionnés par le
par la bd et tous et didier en fait j'ai
connu lors d'une dédicace au château de
versailles organisé pour le personnel
par un autre gars de fagard de
surveillants chez pas comment il faut
dire de versailles qui nous avait fait
venir didier est un amoureux des comics
et de la bd franco-belge ce dimanche il
veut rencontrer olivier schwarz
dessinateur français je vais connu par
les séries de s'appeler l'inspecteur
bayard
c'était destiné aux enfants qui
paraissait dans okapi et olivier jeu
farce
est devenu le dessinateur est un
dessinateur de la série spirou donc
maintenant il est beaucoup plus connu
quatre ans quand tu disais juste
l'inspecteur bayard où c'était facile de
le voir là maintenant c'est un peu plus
compliqué je m'étais autant d'énergie et
d'amour à rien aujourd'hui les choses
que j'ai cette dédicace va rejoindre la
collection de didier ce passionné en
possède aujourd'hui plus de 3000